[Music]
I'm a provider I'm see you a new trick
would repeat a startup
good thing is the start of which helps
you collect customer feedback and I
recorded to a security measure and boost
customer happiness feedback our test
refused our product to get the treatment
in their customers using micro service
like NPS which may have heard something
called a promoter score which is very
simple you know ask you like how high
can you recommend a scale of 1 to 10
your service to your friend then they
give you score and then basically after
once you're discordant explaining why
they gave you 5 vs 6 versus 10 so what
do we tell you do you that you know your
customers will get like hundreds of
thousands of feedback from their
customers and it's very difficult to
make sense of all those feedback because
the bottom of feedback is so huge so
basically the problem we're trying to
solve now it is how can we do
aggregation some analysis for you so
that you can get thing inside lot more
quickly and advantage of getting this
insights is that basically you align
entire your company your line will
company for fiscal what your customers I
care about basically we do have some
as you can see the DocuSign starkers
universe we have for some reason we were
very good at all Santa Bob's companies
like lovely doctor and you run in
reading of this guide you just read it
right and so basically because I've had
never the press are more vocal about
well how they use their product and they
give an order feedback which is really
good for us so with anything you are
using would take or somebody else let's
say you have got a loss of lost observer
feedback now if you're eating n PS or C
sad or CES surveys basically you're
going to have a quantitative feedback
and qualitative feedback if it's
quantitative with them just bunch of
numbers you can do Excel reporting you
can do have low look or any kind of
thing and it basically will be able to
see a train of how your score is going
up or down but then about the
qualitative you know because it's
actually actual plain text and it is
very difficult to analyze so this
talking about it what like what what if
you to help solve that problem so the
problem we're trying to solve for
qualitative feedback is to basically
categorize those feedback into different
buckets I do some sentiment analysis of
it and using agent and this comes from
like categorization and analysis we can
see like what are the themes like they
give somebody a set of customer like a
product Y to the like if they don't like
your product what we do not like it
right and basically you'll be able to
give you a sense of like what customers
at Aqaba
contain example to to to to so that you
all are in the same hey this is actually
real feedback the new dashboard looks
real good but charge takes forever to
load and take a take a resolution is
also
taking longer these days than in the
past
if you manually classified this feedback
we will say look at this this feedback a
part of the talks about usability of the
product and then it's also a customer
support
performance and the sentiment is
actually mix because some part of it if
some part of it is negative and not only
that will be really good if you can
highlight which category in which
category is being positively and which
one is a negative question so this is
this is the end goal we're trying to gap
so I started with Jake in 2016 and we
realized it have lost the feedback
ourselves our customers de brosse the
feedback and they have been basically
manually manually classifying these
feedback categories themselves what
would you do I have been also personally
I would pick it up background but I
don't have machine learning right now
and we need to use machine learning to
solve this problem so how do you go
about it so I said let me let me take a
smaller project of this problem for us
so we said well when I did some research
sentiment analysis is not a new thing
it's been being done for a long time so
one exists out there so I started with
basically my background is in Java you
look for water the Java tools that exist
out there using analysis and I find the
stand for it's time for an ugly library
which is open source you know and
everything it has a pretty good app eus
appears in MLP might know a part of a
part of a speech tagging so it tells you
what is a noun for effective and things
like that and they see it on several it
also allows you to basically construct a
dependency graph where you can see if
this is the noun which were which
relates to other things like that and my
initial thinking was that I'll be able
to leverage all of this to basically
come up with a good sentiment for for
the feedback
so I think that they deployed it and it
worked well but it did not really work
well for like a longer feedback and
feedback
moisés so and another thing one that
because I did not have machine learning
back at the time I did not know how to
basically create a new model is specific
for Stanford library so that when I get
a new feedback and add new data I can
train it better to give me a better
sentiment score for it so I said I
wasn't oh that was a good experiment
that gave me a break
I could understanding of the problem I
try to solve but I was still looking for
a better solution and we are would think
is like 15 people company my entire game
is like six people and we're trying to
solve this problem so I didn't have a
whole lot of back into the second
experiment so second thing and then at
the same time Google Cloud introduced
beta version of the natural language API
which basically gave opposite everything
that Stanford has a bigger except our
shooting API and in work for me and and
because it was a comparison when it
didn't work I was able to interact with
the team over there give them the
feedback and the skills that would make
those some changes which gives us which
gave us more confidence that sentiment
is going to be good now you know it's
very hard problem to solve in human Lang
you may speak in a very complex way so
it's not accurate and one example here
you see the sample feedback it gives a
lot of information you cannot get on
your own this is very good good feedback
but we feel that with anything close
knit a Google API would tell you that it
is a negative sentiment reverse it right
so my point is that Google with all this
machine learning about it if they don't
get it right all the time frosting it
right at a time so that's an example so
what we do for this e that we allow our
customers to physical manually of into
sentiment if they think something is
wrong so this is just one part of the
problems we trying to solve right like
what it doesn't demand the real part is
the feedback classification so in the
example that I gave earlier how do you
say it's about UX UI
documentation quality customer support
etc so my research continues and
obviously there is a hybrid on yeah and
the sense I got one that well you know
if you are doing supervised learning and
all you need is a bunch of label data
and you can copy a piece of code from
from the internet and the loss of them
and basically be able to run the model
and it should be able to be able to
basically get a good prediction out of
your edge solution and on top of that
that - we have because we've been in the
business for four years and our
customers have basically manually
categorize lots of feedback so they're
like hundreds and thousands of manually
in the label they tied to to apply to
all right well one will go wrong okay
obviously we failed miserably because
you know just it was categorization was
totally totally wrong like a lot of time
so I at this time I'm I'm hard an intern
who knows more about data science and
NLP than I do so you can look into it
with what would happen and the the
biggest reason was the training dinner
party so even though our customers have
spent a lot of time manually classifying
feedback into different categories the
definition of the howard equal usability
and price and quality is gonna be
definitely very different from for
burritos definition so there is no
consistency so you shouldn't deny is not
consistent level this machine learning
you because when i inherited both bias
is an inconsistency at one part of it
second of all there's q2 distribution of
labels so like some neighbors like
usability the price and quality will
find lots of course of training data for
but something like feature if you ask
customer support we won't have many okay
so basically that was one other problem
second thing we like that the problem
space was too big i inaudible wire that
will build this amazing machine learning
algorithm which give a feedback and we
will classify that into many of them on
different categories that were just not
there
yeah just some an example like why like
why is it more difficult
to solve so the fix is when we give you
a lot well let's narrow down the problem
so that when we look at the data we
realize that the many people talk about
atom of problem is going to be different
from the public accommodations some
other product but if you change your
machine learning model for one thing of
feedback for once in a product then I
believe my work and also we basically
shorten the list of categories we can
break the feedback because instead of
initially stuff like 20 that we had we
made it like a shorter day so that at
least where we're going to give me that
category
categorization is more hybrid second
thing with that we needed to have a high
quality training data so instead of
relying on our customer sector we spent
our sprint very tired he company was
actually manually lose every data for a
different product category and and we
made sure that one person actually
product everybody so that even if
there's a bias at this we know this part
from that files from that perspective
and fix it in the next iteration we
differ explore different algorithms
started with simple bag of words
different classifiers and our first path
second path we use word to back with PCA
so basically you have the factory built
in to talk to you were thinking of like
this here to see which would which is
one vector is more important for that
feedback and then you basically go
through different classifier to come
with I come up with a score of what the
feedback is about then as we got more
comfortable with machine learning and
realist him the other some of the
project or system the problem basically
we're solving is a multi-level
classification process so that's why you
that the last function you see is the
binary cross-entropy and all these other
matrix well now we also have CNN all in
a some some one 100 them work better for
certain tags not not even every
algorithm works for all tags and the
reason may be that the kind of training
data we have the ball
we have I don't know I don't understand
personally how the internals of enough
to understand what could be causing this
but I don't know that Solomon is not
always the best algorithm for for this
and CNN is not always the best for us as
well but overall for our our problem
space the CNN gives us the best best
performance and I think it's because
it's support within this team that
should give me a better one I think the
reason it was probably my hypothesis is
that customer feedbacks are very short
and most of the others TM examples that
you see is about the blogs and news
articles and you know very very small
feedback maybe that's part of it in
production we don't all fall for
algorithms in production and basically
we do across across valued validation on
the fly to see which tag should be of
which algorithm should be where more for
this particular category regardless of
ugliness you know we you know the
accuracy is is good but it's not good
all the time so we've made it as simple
for our customers to basically update so
they will say if they if they if they if
engine and our cost because it has
applied category to a feedback that they
do not like they can easily access
update in the UI I didn't know what
happens in other because of new training
data all the time
we even have implemented this job a
continuous learning class so that's how
online will be processed where our model
will get up take it up to deploy again
but there is something with the natural
flow and chaos lesson that when you
update the model on the runtime for
whatever reason how the classification
was wrong so we don't do it in the we
don't do it live anymore between on a
weekly basis as we get more feedback we
basically go through our validation and
deploy the high part hard water is there
does the CIC need the training you
basically
impose operator love looking up
Cole and you have the input data and you
ever see learning actually or input it
has sort of each part of the code
because you know that's how this thing
works so it was the boundary between
code in the data how do you how do you
further them properly and this is still
something we're trying to figure out as
well
lessons learned I have only one minute
left it is a very hard problem
I specifically of a small number of
Engineers start with we need to rely on
lots on soldiers of giants so the
research paper from Google Microsoft
Facebook they have done lots of work out
there basically and most importantly I
told the king that is all exercise may
not go anywhere we are not an expert yet
so that was very important and second
part I would say the lessons learned is
that algorithms are easy actually
Allen in CNN some very complex but the
code is somebody has done it for you
the hard part was to how do you probably
have the consistent training data how do
you how do you parse they come what kind
of encoding you have to use to make sure
that you machinery call you don't you
can work better how do you get lots of
human classified data to train your
model go through and actually the harder
problem then actually applying certain
algorithm that you can just copy paste
and oh I just thought the interesting
templates for example Michelle
entrusting this feedback is actually is
not a negative sentiment is customers
think you really did a good job but you
know that's this one of example you need
to be do on how to set a color if we
just do like a bag of force this will be
tagged as video or when it's not
required many ways our documentation and
lots of feedbacks are going to be very
simple word like expensive cool and
things like that so how do you
physically classify this property
hopefully this give some some insights
into problems related to and what way
[Music]
has come so one of the things you
mentioned and one of the last lines was
deployment until like a production
system is kind of difficult you maybe
talk a little bit more about how
individual engineers developed what that
process looks like are you guys
validating your conjectures on like a
small set of data like how does that
decision get made where you guys go from
like Alice TM to like Siena like how do
you guys actually prove the goodness of
this like new algorithm before deploying
it into a production stage yeah yeah so
the question is like how do you how do
you know that this algorithm is working
and expected and when we get a new
training data how do you validate that
it should work and the way we do it
across while we're developing in the
beginning and I think you when used in
the production is to we do cross
validation so basically we have a set of
a set of feedback that's human labeled
and across that it is noteworthy that
we'll take 90% of those feedback for
training 10% of tasks and this is
happening iteratively all the time so
when we get a new set of training data
before we decline to production
we're on the same cross validation test
again and when they deploy to production
if it had passed with i2 choosing one
algorithm versus another
I'd say I do not know why on this team
works better for certain types of
categories and ycn
I don't know why but we know that it
worked better for certain categories and
so basically we took the censer ensemble
algorithm where we basically took every
output from every algorithm into
consideration yeah yeah so I actually
use the mic for once some of those
models are a lot take a lot longer to
train how bigger the purposes for quiet
that you work with and do you feel that
there's a trade off from your production
items like this to prefer faster
inference models yeah so person is how
big is you know the data like how long
do the planning two runs good thing with
text is that the scientist site is not
human like image or video so even though
even though you have a 10,000 label but
the HTM and CNN actually even for that
scale actually takes us like two more
than twelve hours then in the model
which we would just store on s3 you know
point where you can do hyper foreigner
optimization we already know that if you
want to be already we already do every
different branch right now but with CNN
will change in the filter size and
Colonel side to see was wondering if you
also got a chance to kind of around its
unsupervised when something like
which is very common in Texas which
process environment yeah we are we try
the LDA and he'll fill in for us because
and they say most of the feedbacks are
like to line long so and the LD a DS for
the coffee topic classification he
stated in his articles and blogs so it
doesn't work for us we knew he was
unsupervised learning and that I did
mention here to basically anomaly
detection in the sense that with this
catastrophe password because the word
functional feedback together and see
what is that nominee so between that for
that
you